hey Alexa play I remember bye Alexa stop
hey Alexa stop yeah Alexis still trying
to figure it out that's cool right yeah
of course 2016 that's what kind of push
those those society when we go into the
streets of different seas and speak to
people about topics and so abandoned
about social media abortion or that
topics that people have say on the other
than creative people just show us tell
us what they think about [ __ ] and
from there we managed to go from number
25 thousand followers and different kind
of social spaces topic is Instagram
Samba 4,000 now yeah things are going
well but what can you really want to use
to kind of show you and you just kind of
dissect everything you think you've an
idea of what we sort of do so ideally
just start people topical questions on
the street and also speaks or to
influencers of the book to kind of
format with muddy streets speak to
people and what I think even though my
mother for now
associated when President of India UK
and they gave a spell force and what's
happening in the world as a sign I've
always thought Street video would always
always work like I'm very hot on it I
think it always plays like I'm a big
believer in this genre like the
late-night shows did it like everything
I'm a big believer in I think the bigger
question is what do you want to happen
that part I understand after that like
okay so you grow it yeah so yeah
millions of eyes on it let's go to the
next step mmm what are you here to be a
nonprofit social justice thing do you
want to make a trillion dollars do you
want to sell t-shirts do you want to
sell it to news corp do you want to like
I think I think I think growing it I you
know I can give you some and we have a
limited time here so I want to give you
the most value here's how I think about
that how to grow it the best way for you
to grow it is to watch what I do not
what I say right so that that I think I
can help you with by you just paying
more close attention to why I'm growing
yeah like why do I am at which studio
why why do I go on you know why am I
trying to go on live more like all those
things that you're more you know more
than welcome to ask those questions here
I think the more important question I
have is what do you want to happen when
it has a million followers like I assume
you want it to be a profitable business
right so that's why I wanted to go there
so let's go about a different way I
think too many people go this route I'm
gonna spend two years building this and
then I can go to BMW or Manchester
United or you know the booths and get
money from them to be an sponsor yeah I
would argue that you may want to think
about it a different way and you can get
the same money from those people right
now by showing them that you can do this
kind of content and so I think a lot of
people in your position wait and try to
do a business model that's based on
advertising and I think you can start
tomorrow and build a business based on
service watch what I do not what I say
I didn't first build a media company
even though I had Wine Library TV right
I built an agency and then I bought a
media company in pure well and I'm
launching one next week that you guys
are gonna read every day because it's
really about us right I mean I can see
it already you have a sense I want to
look at it again but like I can have a
sense that you know what to do so you
know what I would do I would DM small
and medium and big sized businesses in
the UK every day until the account is
blocked and said hey we're das and and
we'd like to do this for you and we can
make videos we can ask people about the
issues of your business
like this yeah and you can put on your
channels and we can put on our channels
and they'll be like how much is that
you're like oh it's like five thousand
pounds one big one said a good quote so
they've got about seven point eight so
we offered them to do the monday
motivation videos on the shoe salon for
different sees more and more expensive
[Applause]
next we're actually doing something
[Applause]
in hobby college more interesting
Authority same day
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
five million views on Facebook and also
going to tar which is a big thing the
biggest thing the biggest thing I would
tell you that you should do so back to
spitting it I think you're getting
caught I think you're going to heavy I
think you're going to heavy I think all
of the content is in your direction so I
think about supply and demand I think
this stuff is heavy and I think
everybody's getting sucked into heavy
cuz there's negativity in the system
yeah I if I were you so if I became the
third prize okay guys I want to be the
third partner like oh you should Gary me
once we have third partner you'd be like
all right Gary B what should we do right
the number one thing I would do based on
what I'm seeing here is even some of the
stuff that's lighter weight has deeper
meaning you know bombing Syria heavy
period heavy plus-sized models not as
heaviest bombing Syria but we're still
talking heavy [ __ ] right vegans you can
still make everything here it has
political undertone yeah I think you
guys subconsciously think that's smart
because it gets polarizing reactions I
think it's not smart as you think
because everybody's doing it and there's
fatigue in the system let me give an
example if every third one here was Coke
or Pepsi man you or man City your your
your your media company would be much
better
you're heavy and you need to give people
an appetizer before the main meal okay
with the everything you ever be if it's
a recent way we're gonna go yeah go back
no I think you heard what I said
every I think you need to mix high and
low at all times
yeah yeah you know I don't know if you
look at the thing that would get a bunch
of comments on Instagram like easy
engaging people just and not paragraphs
I said it's it's great other than I
think you could get pay dirt by look
you're doing all the right things like
your screenshots are so on point
what's that the mean borders are
commoditized the people you're putting
in the pictures are exactly right here
right here are the pretty girls here is
the clearly Israeli dude here's like
your you guys are giving good thought I
so I think you're doing a lot of things
right I think you're doing one macro
thing wrong I think you need to my
opinion I think you're going down a path
everybody is going down the negative
like nobody looks big you know what's
sad right now people view this is
negative this is thoughtful conversation
I wouldn't argue it that it's nugget I
don't think it's negative I think they
think it's negative and it gets heavy
and and they're it's not um I think you
have to try I don't think I'm right I
think you have to see if there's any
right and where I'm going
yeah I think it's a clever thing that
might that would be my first observation
and what do you think going straight to
gospel I think the other thing is you
have to use more hashtags oh you're
using them on the first post okay good
nope and I'm okay with it
the other thing I would do is I would
transcribe it
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's like you should do that but it's so
hard I laughed so hard when I sing music
and I will not say it but no it's funny
for back to black friends like in
college my friends like wanted me to to
his point yeah they were kind like what
you're never worried about I'm never
worried about what dirac thinks of me
cuz he knows all my truths yeah you
never you know what I mean you never
want somebody to think you're doing the
wrong thing if you can help it
[Applause]
these are what you guys try to move it's
just where you're where you guys are at
even when you try to do it a little
lighter it's got a negative it's why do
you think why do you think I'm probably
doing well I'm by default optimistic my
video would have been biggest
opportunity it's the same thing you see
where I'm going I feel like 40 years ago
but let's talk about like kind of heavy
topics the thing that I've been spending
a lot of time on I just can't stop
thinking about it which is I go on
Breakfast Club as a 42 year old wealthy
white man and my things that are coming
out of my mouth are nobody gives a [ __ ]
which is like if you read it on paper
you would be like this guy's gonna get
murdered by the culture but it's the
reverse because
it's coming from a good place I'm not
saying nobody gives a [ __ ] because I
think I'm better than you or I don't
like you it's that I know that the
second you actually realize that then
you can start yeah because if you're
holding on right doesn't mean I don't
play the truth you know what I mean it's
just like I've keeps to like everybody's
got truths like if you're if you're what
I always bring up the super white rich
person they're [ __ ] up more their
truth is nobody will nobody in this room
now I know all four I mean I don't know
you guys but just the color your skin
gives you an estimate and I know us
nobody's gonna feel bad for twenty-five
million dollar trust fund baby Tyler but
guess what if that person happens to
also be ambitious and wants to have a
reputation for himself he's finished
there's us four can get out of our
situation and win he can't no matter
what he accomplishes they'll be like Bri
I guess he can actually you go and
always do something to just give it all
the way and start it's here and that's
probably what he has to do so anyway
that is super interesting to me I think
you need to because I think the nature
of banter and points of view is far more
powerful for example I think that I'm
gonna help entrepreneurs some people a
lot more I think I almost use my
personality and my optimism as a trick
to get people to do the right thing I'm
gonna get a lot more with honey than
vinegar I think if you guys mixed in
some lightweight [ __ ] your other
hard-hitting [ __ ] will lay in to better
you like I look at that and I can see a
lot of people they like this is agenda
driven okay see where I'm going I think
man you man City is real world you got
world cup coming up nice and light you
couldn't even have still has you know
some things in it cuz it's cut up sOooo
I'm going I mean you know I don't know
the London market well but like the
cronut was this big craze in Manhattan
I'm sure there's some food or restaurant
right now poppin that everyone wants to
talk about or
push a Drake yeah I think you guys have
permission for that see I'm going I
think one out of every three or four one
out of every five even if you want a key
I don't want to deviate you from your
mission but I will tell you the thing
that things like this do wrong is is
yeah yeah yeah and then you're just like
all right I've been eating this heavy
meal like you gotta have salad sometimes
you gotta have [ __ ] a cupcake once in
a while you want to get people to eat
healthy don't make them 100% vegan yeah
make it okay to eat a [ __ ] something
and I'm not that you know not that
that's the point yet but you sure I'm
going I feel like I figured out my
weight cuz I don't beat myself up if I
have one bad day like I've been on point
like okay yeah I want to get tighter a
little bit right now but like one bad
day like on the flight out like I've
been like getting my [ __ ] together again
a little bit like even tighter and like
I didn't have a good day on the flight
here because I was trying to fall asleep
and wine and food I'm just trying to go
to sleep if I just kept beating myself
up I'd be four days it but yesterday
fast and easy and how to pick a couple
things I picked that like you just got
it's a very important thing and I just
think that's what's happening here it's
like boom boom boom and if you're really
into it you love it until you don't but
you're making it a very narrow thing
okay it's so funny that makes me laugh
because this I believe in as soma I want
to do so much of this like I want to do
it a lot we're actually gonna do some
stuff like this
it'll be like man-on-the-street two
minutes man the street is [ __ ] good
[ __ ]
listen brother' blowing something up
it's just patience here's why you never
know here's why I like man you man City
do you know many people aren't gonna
[ __ ] with this content cuz it's heavy
eight out of ten because right now
everyone's like enough of getting
[ __ ] into political debates
[Music]
and all you need is one man you player
to [ __ ] give it love tell you right
now optimism and light and happy and
smiles wins today now look at me I'm
that I don't shy away from heavy stuff I
talk about suicide but when you're just
one or the other way I don't dodge and
I'm not just like no it's all rainbows I
go you know you guys know my content I
can't you never really know exactly
what's gonna happen you know it might be
heavy might not but like I think that's
where you can get more virality it may
be Syria bombing because BBC does
something somebody else or whatever the
[ __ ] the the Prince that thinks it
took a piece of can't like sure but it
could also be cheeseburgers or chicken
wings and I think you should give
yourself a little bit of room and I
think I think you should DM micro
influencers I would say 10 to 20,000 and
be like we just like your stuff and we'd
love to have you as one of the opinion
people in here so I would when you make
them you have I wouldn't even like
making a knowledge meant to it either
instead of making them the default you
know first of all they're gonna tag it
yeah and second of all it's just like a
easter egg you give people reason to
watch you never know when [ __ ] nigel
thompson shows up for no reason see
where I'm going it's kind of like oh
it's a wink like you can't imagine how
much [ __ ] we're doing let me phrase he
doesn't even know I do so many little
Easter eggs to mice not even d-roc I'm
doing it for myself or to my team so
I'll give you a previous literally gonna
be announced ASAP so the new men's which
is like Complex meets of ice meets
Forbes meets Gary Vee it's gonna be
called 137 p.m. that's gonna be my site
and I'm gonna hope you watch it every
day I'm gonna doing some cool [ __ ]
interviewing people content we just put
out a shirt that I sold an empathy is a
superpower it's like a comic book and in
there it says 5 cents which is my
favorite number 5 but also this is vol 1
30
nobody knows why that's there but now
like you know like I love that kind of
[ __ ] and people love that kind of [ __ ]
you know people you know you love that
[ __ ] like Oh like when like like wait a
minute in that first movie in this
trilogy they actually made the head nod
to what just played out [ __ ] you know
and that's what I'm doing I'm doing all
sorts of little things that like I can
point to episode 12 and be like you'll
be like oh my it's gonna be like oh he's
been thinking about this
this isn't luck mm-hmm pleasure yeah yes
oh there we go I'm excited I love that
here we go yes yes yes oh my god I'm so
pumped right now oh I love it
I'm literally gonna wear this literally
gonna wear this I can't wait I'm gonna
have Simon up every team Vaynerchuk 5
Jersey of every [ __ ] seat before this
is all done the debate is on what is
going to be the squad I see that's
amazing
Iraq you have to have to have to make
sure I get that okay
I remember being from I know it bought
his money I'm gonna look up like where
everybody's uh I remember sleeping on